i want to start with congrats on the
movie i thought james did such a great
job as well uh and both of you um i just
have nothing but positive things to say
thank you
um i know james has been talking about
making this movie for like years this
has been like his passion project for so
long what was it actually like working
with him on set because i heard that he
would uh like dance and sing and just
had a very unique energy
yeah
we yeah man he
you i don't know if you've had a chance
to interview him yet but he does have a
unique energy and and that energy has
you know i've known him for over 15
years maybe even longer has never
changed you know he's exactly who he was
when he was daydreaming this idea
to who he is sitting at the press
conference in london the same person and
that person and that energy transfers to
the way he makes his movies you know um
you know
if you have a question for james you
better put away 20 minutes okay to get
the answer because
he's going to give you the full-fledged
um
answer but that's really as actors and
you know speaking for regina as well it
really did put us in the picture you
know we got his vision you know and
both regina and i have directed so and i
know i'm pretty sparing i like a actor
to take away and do what he wants but
but but james allowed us to do that but
he really painted
his his vision and that was really
incredible and that's part of his energy
do you want to add anything regina
uh no i think idris said it all that
honestly
to to
to
you can only
understand fully
uh what idris is saying about james by
meeting him i mean even though it's
maybe a 20-minute answer
you're entertained the whole time he's
truly a storyteller
he's also
i would say he's like
the guy at the liquor store
telling the story and he's also this
great visionary at the same time telling
a reimagined um
story when i say reimagine meaning that
all of these characters are real people
and the reimagining is how they all
cross paths
he also has an encyclopedia knowledge of
uh westerns he's obsessed with the with
the uh which makes him a great director
for this i would say an encyclopedia
knowledge of film yeah 100
um you guys
wanted to clarify that you know james
isn't
he he's not at the liquor store he's
not 100 you guys have worked in many
different uh genres and many different
types of films what was it actually like
making a western like this versus maybe
what you expected going in
i mean we expected it to be you know in
a lot of regards what it is because
james was so clear with his vision this
is
this is james has lived with this
forever i mean i'll let uh idris speak
to that because he's
been there from the beginning
yeah i'd say like we we expected this
you know i mean i to be honest though
you know and i can say this to him and
all of us we didn't expect it to
uh
uh hit in the way it has
you know
this this film has been brewing for a
long time but the the climate of where
the world is and that appetite for
something like this we could not have
written you know what i mean like you
talk about it's black history month in
the uk and here you have a
western
with black characters that people don't
even know about and forgot about
and it hits so hard here and so you know
we couldn't have expected that but
everything that he
envisioned
from the first time when he's telling
you about a scene takes his guitar and
starts singing the score
you're like oh my god and then you see
it we expected it to be what it is you
know
uh yet one of the things about a western
is you always get to do a third act
shootout so there's always a big third
out action sequence so what was it like
actually filming this one and and being
part of a big third out third act
western sequence
well rufus buck was lucky he
he he didn't get dirty
i remember saying to james so
rufus
is
not
going to
be anywhere in this fight
okay why are you trying to get me to do
more days come on man
i just wanted more time with you i just
wanted more time
no i think it's fantastic i mean i don't
i don't think um
you know and some of the things that
jonathan majors does in in that uh third
act shootout as you say action sequence
is just phenomenal you would think that
he's been
he was riding a horse before he could
drive a car
but it was it was fun it was exciting
[Music]
i was going to say i just have an
individual question for each of you
before i run out of time regina
when are you getting back behind the
director's chair and idris as a huge fan
of luther uh what can you tease people
about the upcoming movie
um i'll be getting but depending on how
things go with the strike i'll be
back behind the chair um
spring next year
bitter root
very cool
um i
will be
also in bitterroot uh did i say that no
sorry
no um luther is um we have an incredible
appetite to uh satisfy the audience that
love luther in its current form as a tv
show
uh but also bring it into a new sphere
with the film version you know um i
don't want to be controversial but you
know people imagine me as bond and
that's great but i'd love can't wait to
see them as luther
in that in this movie um and and i
really really are our ambition is to
take it there take it there i'm so
excited for it i'm so excited
i've been a fan of luther for a very
long time i am over the moon you guys
are doing this movie thank you
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say again congrats on this movie you
guys did such a great job
thank you for your time
thank you